humility is stupid because if you look  it up on Google it says thinking less of  oneself this is why looking and defining  terms is important because if you look  at Merriam-Webster for example it's lack  of Pride or arrogance I don't think  people would say you wouldn't want that  I'm like I think people are okay not  being prideful arrogant but even more so  and the definition that I have taken on  is actually the exact opposite of that  it is not decreasing your regard for  self but increasing your regard for  others I thought that posturing when I  was younger was the thing that would get  people to like me what I realized later  was that you gain status by giving more  to the group than you get